the 8.9 mile gap between European and
African continent known as the Strait of
Gibraltar is home to multiple strange
territories and borders on the European
side which is 2.6 square mile British
overseas territory named your altar this
means that Britain chose a small land
border with Spain on the African side of
the street is the Spanish city of Ceuta
separate completely from the rest of
Spain this city is an autonomous
community within Spain essentially
having similar rights as the independent
regions that make up Spain a little more
than 100 miles down the African coast of
media another Spanish exclave in
northern Africa all this move of Spain
share significant land borders with
Morocco and that in effect only one
country separates British soil from
African soil to other European countries
also have strange water relations
conventional wisdom would say at the
Netherlands and France not share land
border Belgium stand between the two
countries
however the others are the world the two
countries do share water the Caribbean
island of st. Martin spoke between a
French collectivity samartha and a Dutch
Constituent Colony Sint Maarten meaning
that you can walk from France and
Netherlands without crossing through
another country also part of France is
French Ghana French Guiana has the exact
same political power as any other French
département and region despite being on
the other side of the Atlantic Ocean
it has a comparable relationship as
Hawaii to United States geographically
separated of politically integrated this
means that fran shares a land border
with both Brazil and Suriname II there
are two daily flights from French Guiana
to Paris which make for one of the
longest domestic flights in the world
these flights takeoff in France and land
in France but take nine hours and cross
4401 miles
despite this this is not the longest
domestic flight in the world the longest
is also within France and goes from
Paris to the French overseas department
of colonial locating the Indian Ocean
the flight is 5809 miles long and takes
just over 11 hours and over to North
America it's impossible to walk or drive
from New York to LA without crossing
over water the st. Lawrence River
connects the Great Lakes to the Atlantic
Ocean
then the Chicago River connects to the
Des Plaines River which connects to the
Illinois River which connects to the
Mississippi River which flows out into
the Gulf of Mexico it's also impossible
to go from the south to the north of the
US without crossing water there's one
creek in the Teton wilderness of Wyoming
that divides at a place called the
parting of the waters one side flows
3488 mile Ski Atlantic while the other
1353 miles to the Pacific this means
that this is one of the few natural
waterways connecting the Atlantic to the
Pacific near those Great Lakes that make
up part of the water split is middle
Island Canada the southernmost point in
Canada a majority of US states
27 actually live fully or partially
north at this point the closest point in
Europe to the u.s. is the dingle
peninsula in Ireland only 2539 miles
away from Hamel Maine the island of
Ireland is politically divided between
the autonomous country of the Republic
of Ireland and the section of Great
Britain called Northern Ireland although
despite the name the northernmost part
of the island of Ireland is not in
Northern Ireland its Malin Head or the
Republic of Ireland now to finish it off
we'll head up to normally Norway's land
stretches over Sweden and Finland to
actually share a border with Russia on
the other side of Eurasia Russia also
shares a tiny 11 mile border with North
Korea this means that only one country
separates the analytic social democracy
in Norway from the communist
dictatorship of North Korea let's say
the aliens track on those tracks are
five Charlie's barreling down these
tracks no absolute certainty
hello there's a side trend with one man
on it